hey hey New Kids on the Block here is
from Iowa really actually this a lot of
oceans in Iowa
no just ponds and lakes and cocky pretty
boys image what happened to that last
pretty boy recruit we have he died what
is this late third hazing Annette Brodie
oh the world record in the 200-meter yes
absolutely we still never really heard a
guy's sing that song but they're really
good thank you by the way let me shower
in here huh
I don't mean to interrupt but every one
of the beaches talking about you guys
thank you well I just wanted to invite
all of you to the Huntley look I know
that the club's kind of fancy and
probably not your scene but you have a
standing invitation thank you oh okay
do you just look at my boobs I was not
my intention I didn't feel like right
now now I did cuz we were talking about
testing Oh failed oh my god all right he
just like something again no I was you
never forget the one who steals your
heart or the one who kicks your ass some
[ __ ] [ __ ] is happening on our Beach
and my balls say we need to go over
there and check it out is it bad idea
Mitch we're lifeguards my balls say it's
just take it he's right
well my balls are saying [ __ ] that noise
let's go handle business your balls are
bullies
Baywatch works because we follow rules
[Applause]
this is a train wreck and not a single
[ __ ] was given is where the best
swimmers in the whole world it's like if
a human [ __ ] a jetski which is
impossible but be so cool
[Music]
don't jack off on my sheets just
remember I'm always watching beyond
madness
[Music]
All Things Considered these gonna get a
lot worse
foot that's good luck pick it up
my dog we need to search the morgue for
evidence
check his tank for you two marks the
woman to check his taint lifts his
[ __ ] scrotum and check his taint
dude it's a taint man it's Italian even
look get closer
Oh yogurt oh there's a hole that's just
his bottle all smile most of that do not
post that just a handful of ball sack
turn canals into the goddamn X Games
that's cuz we were in lifeguard pursuits
oh okay
except for this no [ __ ] such thing
this lifeguard pursuit
[Music]
[Music]